[Music]
hello everyone
uh through this lecture we are going to
discuss a very short a mini chapter
on constitutive relations now instead of
just uh presenting you these relations
let me see if i can motivate the need
for this
relations now what you have done till
now is in the first chapter we discussed
uh the kinematics uh and the second one
we discussed stress and through this
uh through these discussions we uh we
presented a number of equations
so let's take stock of what we have till
now and
what we possibly need okay so first of
all
we uh especially while discussing
the balance of linear momentum i i
stressed very much
that we are very much taking into
account
the balance of mass okay so
to the balance of mass
or mass conservation
we have this continuity equation and
again i want to emphasize
that although perhaps
we first studied this continuity
equation in the context of fluid
mechanics but this is something which is
very much
uh applicable for solid mechanics also
in fact for any continuous mechanics
studies now in this equation how many
unknowns do we have
we have the row the density which in
general will consider
as unknown in addition to that we have
the three unknown components of the
velocity vector
now especially in the kinematics chapter
the first chapter on kinematics
we did not really talk with about
velocities unlike field mechanics
instead we talked
talked about the displacement vector but
you all know
from your earlier studies that the
velocity vector
is defined in this fashion
okay and it was also mentioned earlier
so the velocity vector can be defined as
the material time derivative of the
displacement vector
so uh when we are talking about the
velocity vector we
we can alternatively think of that we
are actually talking about
the the displacement vectors because if
we know the displacement vectors we
certainly know the
velocity vectors okay so in this
equation we have
uh the number of unknowns as
row one of them and three velocity
vectors alternatively the three
displacement vectors
so four in total okay so let's say like
this
rho is one unknown and
the velocity or the velocity vector or
the displacement vector
that gives us three unknowns next
from the balance of our linear momentum
from the balance of linear momentum
we ultimately arrived at this particular
equation
we actually arrived at the cautious
equation of motion
but considering static equilibrium we we
arrived at this equation
now here you see how many unknowns are
here so
i am i am
implicitly embedding within this
equation the information that
sigma is equal to sigma transpose
and if you remember from the previous
chapter on stress
i had mentioned that from the balance of
angular momentum
uh we arrive at this equation provided
we don't have any body
tuples present so you can consider that
from this balance of linear momentum
where we actually use the balance of
mass and we're also using this balance
of angular momentum so all of that
information
is encapsulated in this equation and how
many really
really how many unknowns are present
here so in this
sigma stress tensor we have six
independent
components and these will consider as
unknowns
okay so in this sigma there are six so
in total how many we have
one plus three four plus six ten
unknowns till now
and these are the equations that we have
so
we have how many equations here so this
is a single equation
and this here is basically three
equations
okay so we have uh we have mentioned
that the expanded version of this uh
would be the uh would be the
three stress equilibrium equations uh
written in the form
del sigma 1 1 del x 1 plus del sigma 1 2
del
x 2 plus del sigma 1 3 del x 3 plus rho
v 1
as the first component and similarly for
the second component and the third
component
so in total we have three equations here
and one equation here
so overall we have four equations so
this is
just one equation and this one
is three equations
okay so overall we have four equations
here and here we have
uh 10 unknowns so we have uh so four
equations
but we have 10 unknowns
so we have a six equation discrepancies
so
the easy fix is to introduce six uh
equations
and we are going to do that through
discuss your div relations by presenting
this constitutive relations but you will
see that there is a subtlety involved
there
now where do we get these constitutive
relations so
uh in a very simple fashion
very very roughly speaking for these
constitutive relations
we rely on experiments okay and you have
been exposed to these
kinds of relations in your first year
mechanic study as well as in your
second year fluid mechanics or thermofit
science courses
so
i'm sure all of you remember the hooke's
law and the generalized hooke's law
what we are going to present uh is again
a version of that
but it is important to remember that
uh when we are talking in general about
constitutive relations
okay so these constitutions it is not
just
that uh the the constitutive relations
is just a fancy way of saying
hooke's law okay so constitutive
relations is much more general
uh so you can have various various
different combinations of relations
uh between the stresses and the strains
between the stresses
and the velocities and together this
entire
possibility the entire
list of possibilities of relations those
are uh commonly captured by this term
constitutive relations and hope's law is
just one single
very simple example of that but very
very widely used all throughout the
engineering domain
so for the purpose of our current course
of mechanics of solids we are going to
discuss
uh this generalized hooke's law again uh
but what we'll say is that we'll try to
make it a little bit
more refined so what we'll say is that
we are interested
in linear
elastic
isotropic materials much in the same way
that when you were considering newtonian
fluids you definitely considered
a linear and isotropic behavior we did
not mention the word
elastic there ah because we didn't need
it there but now we need it
so uh that's what we'll say that the
kind of materials that we'll be dealing
with exclusively
in our course of mechanics of solids
will be linear elastic isotropic
materials
okay so this is very very important so
linear elastic isotropic materials
now when we do that what is the relation
we have
so earlier in your first year mechanics
when we talked about
generalized hooke's law you first of all
express the various components of the
strains in terms of the stresses
now we'll take a different approach
we'll try to we'll try to express the
stresses
directly in terms of the strings and
that will do in the next page
so uh and because we are familiar
somewhat familiar with the index
notation let's try to express it like
that
so for linear elastic isotropic
materials
what we have is this particular relation
so what is this basically what is going
on here so you notice first of all
that this lambda and this g
these are the these are what are
referred to
as the lamy parameters basically these
are two material constants
okay so these this two
are material constants
furthermore this term epsilon kk you
note that
this is basically uh using the repeated
index
so we'll have this the expanded version
of this else epsilon 1 1 plus epsilon 2
2 plus epsilon 3 3.
you also note that
whenever we have
this i not equal to j so suppose we have
sigma 1 2
or sigma 2 3 or sigma 3 1 then this term
is not going to appear
because we have already because we
already know that when i is not equal to
j
this chronicle delta it gives us a 0. in
which case
what we'll have is something like sigma
1 2 is equal to twice g
epsilon 1 2 okay and
sigma 2 3 is equal to twice g epsilon 2
3 sigma 3 1 is equal to y c epsilon 3 1
it is only for the normal stress
components the sigma 1 1
the sigma 2 2 and the sigma 3 3 that
will have the presence of this term
and in that particular case uh this term
is only going to contribute
to one okay you should not be confused
by the fact that when i is equal to j it
should be a repeated index it's not like
that we're talking about very specific
values of the index here so when you set
i
equal to 1 and j equal to 1 this is i
equal to 1 and j equal to 1
and then it is just delta 1 1 and delta
1 1 is very much
zero however if as as you've seen in the
previous chapter in certain problems
when we have delta ii delta ii is equal
to 3
okay so let me just write this down as a
special note
that delta ii is equal to 3 because
delta ii
is delta 1 1 plus delta 2 2 plus delta 3
3 but when you specifically say delta 1
1
that is simply 1 delta 2 2 by itself is
just 1
and delta 3 3 by itself is just 1. so
that's how we should interpret this
there's another way of writing this in
tensor or compact notation so
we write it like this fashion sorry uh
it is the trace of the epsilon trace
means some of the diagonal elements
and this is just the identity tensor
okay so
so these two things are perfectly
equivalent
now you see what is happening it seems
that
uh and furthermore please note that
these relations that we have written
either this one or this one
it does contain within it
uh the six independent components so we
can have
an expression for sigma 1 1 an
expression for sigma 2
2 sigma 3 3 similarly for sigma one two
sigma
two three and sigma three one overall we
have six relations
okay so you understand that this
encapsulates within it six relations
either this or this
same thing
and it seems that our problem is solved
because in the previous page if we just
look
uh we had this discrepancy of six
equations
here we had four equations here and ten
unknowns and it seems that our problem
is solved
but there is a little bit of a subtlety
in here you note
that although you are familiar with
epsilon but
here in these equations the epsilon was
not coming
now if you are introducing epsilon in
these relations you are effectively
introducing six independent components
again
okay so six equations we have introduced
but in that process we have also
introduced
the six more unknowns
six more unknowns
in the form of
the six independent components of
the strain tensor
now again uh it may seem like bad
but our job is almost done because
you remember from your kinematics
chapter that
but not to worry
because we have
because we have in our hand
tricks please note this number six
strain displacement relations
and through these strain displacement
relations uh
because we have 16 industrial relations
so through these six
strain displacement relations we are
basically connecting
the epsilon i j
to the displacement gradients
okay so it comes a full circle we
started with the
unknown row and this unknown
displacement components
and now through these various equations
we have come back to this thing
so overall now this system is
is very much closed so you can almost
think of it like this
that this is six more equations
so six more equations here but
we have not introduced any more new
unknowns okay
so it's like this i let me repeat uh for
clarity's sake
so we had one unknown here three
unknowns here and only one equation here
again through this equation we had six
unknowns but only three equations so
overall we have
in our balance sheet four equations and
ten unknowns so there was a sixth
equation discrepancy
we managed to introduce six equations
here through these stress strain
relations
but in that process we introduced
apparently
the six unknowns in the form of the
strain components
but now we have uh this
six relations connecting the six new
unknowns the sort of new unknowns
in terms of the original displacement
components so it comes a full circle
and everything is nice and closed so uh
so the new thing that we have really
introduced is basically these relations
okay so these uh these are the
constitutive relations
so you can write this here so these uh
stress strain relations
the six uh stress strain relations are
the constitutive relations
uh but again i want to emphasize that
these are not the only kind of stress
strain relations for another kind of
material maybe for rubber
or for biological tissue you could have
a completely different kind of stress
translation perhaps also involving the
strain rates
okay so uh many other possibilities are
present but for
at least for a course of mechanics of
solids uh we'll be dealing with
only this you also note uh
further that there is a nice connection
with the
generalized hooks flow so in first year
mechanics
in first year mechanics you had come
across things like
epsilon x x is equal to 1 by
e sigma x x minus
nu sigma y y plus sigma zz
then epsilon yy is equal to 1 by e
sigma yy minus nu
sigma xx plus sigma zz
epsilon zz is equal to one by e
sigma zz minus nu sigma xx
plus sigma yy
epsilon xy is equal to 1 by twice g
sigma x y epsilon y z is equal to 1 by
twice g
sigma y z and epsilon zx is equal to
1 by twice t sigma zx
now if you just map the x to 1
the y to 2 and z to 3
these three things these six things is
basically what you are having
here okay and in fact as i had already
mentioned that if you set
i equal to 1 j equal to 2 you are
actually getting sigma 1 2 is equal to
twice g
epsilon 1 2 and you can quickly check in
this third page
that epsilon 1 2 is indeed equal to 1 by
twice is sigma one two
similarly for epsilon two three and f
seven uh three one
however these these three relations
involving the
normal strain components in terms of the
normal stress components
they look a little bit different from
what we have here so
as one of the initial problems of the
problem sheet
you will establish the connection the
algebraic connection
between these material constants the
lambda and the g
with these material constants the
young's modulus and the poisons ratio
okay so nice relations are possible
between this
young's modulus poisson's ratio and the
laminar parameters
lambda and g and you will
see that yourself in the problem sheet
so uh with this
we we can end the mini chapter here
there are lots of
lots of interesting things that can be
developed which is why this chapter
is a mini one but the problem sheet is
almost the same length as the previous
two chapters okay
so uh i think i will have lots of fun
with this particular problem sheet
because it will
it will capture many things which we
discussed in the kinematics chapter than
the stress chapter
and very nicely it will be able to
connect these two chapters
okay and this one this mini chapter the
knowledge from this mini chapter will be
the basis of whatever you will be
learning and applying in the subsequent
chapters
all right thank you very much